all of a sudden these characters were
like all up in each you know out of
nowhere but
johnny and i came out of it better than
before kaylee cuoco and johnny galecki
might be two of hollywood's friendliest
dexes today
but the big bang co-stars were put in a
very awkward
position after they split while filming
their hit
sitcom very sad the two secretly dated
while filming the cbs comedy and quietly
split up early in the show's 12 season
run
and the actress opened up about their
past love during a recent chat with dak
shepard on his podcast armchair expert
we dated really early on for almost two
years it was very early on in the show
i remember when we when we did the pilot
i was just
crushing oh oh hard on
galecki right and he had a girlfriend i
was like i was obsessed
and then the first few episodes we you
know obviously
we would talk and hang out and as things
went on finally we we got drinks one
night
had such a crush on him and i didn't
think that he felt that way about me
you know where this is going we got
together and just fell mad for each
other
for about two years but then we broke up
yeah
and just like all work romances that
come to an end
things got super awkward around the
office thanks to the show's creator
chuck laurie
luckily johnny and i came out of it so
brilliantly we're closer today than we
ever were but
i just remember chuck lori i do remember
when we broke up
you know obviously it was a little
sensitive for a minute but i remember
those weeks that
chuck had written these episodes where
all of a sudden our characters were like
sleeping together every other second the
heart wants what the heart wants leonard
okay kaylee still thinks chuck might
have changed their character's
storylines
quote on purpose to jokingly mess with
them
because that came out of nowhere all of
a sudden these characters were like
all up in each you know out of nowhere
but johnny and i came out of it better
than before
of course now kaylee is married to
equestrian carl
cook she was previously married to
former tennis pro ryan sweeting
but the two split after just 21 months
of marriage in 2015.
during her chat with dax she admitted
her fame was a big problem for her first
husband
i was like i have to be with someone who
really has
their own whether they're famous or not
their own life and
i think what's so cool about carl and
everyone that's gotten to know him
he loves his life and he loves
his equestrian world and his like he's
so cool in that arena
literally in that area so he he gets so
fulfilled
carl and kaylee tied the knot in 2018
and when eti caught up with kaylee in
2019
she said they were having the time of
their lives as husband
and wife kaley happy one-year wedding
anniversary congratulations thank you
very much
carl's the best carl's the best other
than our obviously instagram feud we're
doing really well
carl did post some like kind of candid
photos of you
oh beauties were you okay with that well
he doesn't ask me before he posts them
so
he just he loves a good sleeping picture
favorite thing to do he's just funny oh
no he's a he's his own man
he makes his own instagram decisions
he's bold